This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Oprah Winfrey's hair is an amazing and ever-changing object of design. A quick Google image search of her and you can see it in a dozen different styles. But there's a consistency too. A brand, a familiarity. Like if you took Oprah's face out of all those Google images, so that all you could see was a series of pictures of hair You'd still know it was her and even though she's done weaves and braids and all sorts of styles She's also a natural meaning she doesn't use chemical relaxers to try to straighten her hair
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。奥普拉·温弗瑞的头发是一个令人惊叹且不断变化的设计对象。在谷歌图片上快速搜索一下，你就能看到她十几种不同的发型。但其中也有一种连贯性。一种品牌感，一种熟悉感。就像如果你把奥普拉的脸从所有这些谷歌图片中拿掉，只留下一系列头发的照片，你依然能认出那是她。尽管她尝试过接发、编发和各种各样的造型，但她也保留着天然发质，这意味着她不使用化学直发剂来拉直头发。
And that's actually something Oprah and I have in common that's producer Lila Day from the stoop podcast Which is about stories from across the block diaspora. And since I'm a white guy with very little hair, I'm actually gonna hand this one entirely over to her now. Oprah gives most of the credit for her amazing natural hair to one person. This is Andre Walker who's done my hair for 18 years. And I've been through some really good styles.
这其实也是我和奥普拉的共同点。这是《The Stoop》播客的制作人莱拉·戴，该播客讲述的是关于黑人散居群体的故事。由于我是一个几乎没有头发的白人男性，我现在要把这一部分完全交给她。奥普拉将她那令人惊叹的天然秀发的大部分功劳归功于一个人。这就是安德烈·沃克，他为我打理头发已经18年了。我经历过一些非常好的造型，也经历过一些糟糕的年份。
And a couple of bad years. But right now we're doing the most of it. They've been through some really good styles. And a couple of bad years. But right now we're doing the most fun. They've been really good. You've done amazing jobs. I think it's a very difficult thing to do. And... That's why you need the same person. Who knows your hair doing it all the time as well.
还有几年状态很差。但现在我们正在做最棒的尝试。他们经历过一些非常好的造型，也经历过一些糟糕的年份。但现在我们正在做最有趣的尝试。它们一直都很好。你做得非常出色。我认为这是一件非常困难的事情。而且……这就是为什么你需要同一个人，一个了解你头发的人，一直为你打理。
Audrey, your job is secure. Andre Walker first saw Oprah on her talk show, A.M. Chicago, back in the 80s. I thought she was fantastic. And I was watching her show every morning. And I thought, you know, I want to get to know her. So I sent her some flowers one day, saying, I'm dying to get my hands in your hair.
奥德丽，你的工作很稳。安德烈·沃克第一次在80年代的脱口秀节目《A.M. Chicago》中看到奥普拉。我觉得她太棒了。我每天早上都看她的节目。我想，你知道吗，我想认识她。所以有一天我给她送了一些花，说：“我太想亲手打理你的头发了。”
Please give me a call. He didn't have to do much convincing to get the job. She called me the next day. And I'm thinking, oh my god, that was easy. Andre traveled the globe with Oprah, as she became one of the most important media figures in the world. And he gave her basically every hairstyle imaginable.
请给我打个电话。他没费多大劲就得到了这份工作。她第二天就给我打了电话。我心想，天哪，这太容易了。安德烈跟随奥普拉走遍全球，见证她成为世界上最重要的媒体人物之一。他几乎为她设计了你能想象到的所有发型。
Chen Langth Bob, Barry Layard, and Spikey. That was one of my favorites, you know, Flippy. We did a cover with an afro on her magazine with this huge afro wig that was very popular. God, I can go on and on and on. But beyond Oprah's hair, Andre is known for something else, a system that he created back in the 90s to market his line of hair care products. The system categorizes natural hair types, and it's come to market his line of hair care products. The system categorizes natural hair types and it's come to be known as the hair chart.
陈·朗斯·鲍勃、巴里·莱亚德和尖刺发型。那是我的最爱之一，你知道，翻翘发型。我们在她的杂志封面上做过一个爆炸头造型，戴着一顶非常流行的巨大爆炸头假发。天哪，我可以没完没了地说下去。但除了奥普拉的头发，安德烈还因另一件事而闻名，那就是他在90年代为推广其护发产品系列而创建的一套系统。该系统对天然发质类型进行了分类，并被称为“发质图表”。
Andre Walker hair takes your natural waves never gone for. The hair typing chart consists of four hair types. Within each of those categories there are different sub types. Types one is for straight hair. Types two is for wavy hair. Types three is for curly hair. Types four is for kinky hair., and textured hair. Andre's hair chart shows each type of hair drawn out and labeled. From bigger, loopy curls to super tight cork screws, you can actually cut off a small piece of your hair and compare it to the drawings on the chart to figure out which one you are. I'm what's considered a 4B, so I'm on the kinkier end of the curl spectrum.
安德烈·沃克发质图表涵盖了你从未见过的天然波浪。发质分类图表由四种发质类型组成。在每个类别中，还有不同的子类型。1型是直发。2型是波浪发。3型是卷发。4型是紧密卷发和纹理发。安德烈的发质图表展示了每种发质的绘图和标签。从较大的环状卷发到超紧的螺旋卷，你实际上可以剪下一小撮头发，对照图表上的图画来确定你是哪一种。我属于4B型，所以我处于卷发光谱中较紧密的一端。
And for Andre, it was all about selling his products. If your hair is like this, you buy this product, if it's like that, you buy this other one. Your hair will feel so moist and touchable, you won't know what to do with yourself. Obviously. I found Andre's chart after I decided to go natural. Like a lot of black women, I spent years putting chemical relaxers in my hair to straighten it.
对安德烈来说，这一切都是为了销售他的产品。如果你的头发是这样的，你就买这个产品；如果是那样的，你就买另一个。你的头发会感觉非常滋润且触感柔软，你会爱不释手。显然如此。在我决定回归天然发质后，我发现了安德烈的图表。像许多黑人女性一样，我曾花多年时间使用化学直发剂来拉直头发。
It actually never even occurred to me not to relax my hair until I was living in Cuba where relaxers were hard to come by. And so one day in Cuba, I just decided to do the big chop to cut my hair and let it grow back natural. And it felt like a big deal. For a while, I didn't even know how to manage it. Sometimes I felt frumpy with my short, tight hair that I couldn't even comb through. I put on bright red lipstick and big hoop earrings, anything to get through what some people call the ugly face. All of this was a big change. Not just the hair, but how people reacted to me.
在古巴生活之前，我甚至从未想过不拉直头发，因为在古巴很难买到直发剂。所以有一天在古巴，我决定进行“大修剪”，剪掉头发，让它自然生长。这感觉像是一件大事。有一段时间，我甚至不知道该如何打理它。有时，我留着又短又紧、连梳子都梳不通的头发，感觉自己很邋遢。我涂上鲜红的口红，戴上大圆耳环，想尽一切办法度过人们所说的“丑陋期”。这一切都是巨大的改变。不仅仅是头发，还有人们对我的反应。
In Cuba, I went from being called Mulata, which is more of a mixed girl, to Negra, which is Black Girl. I.E. you look negra now. But somehow Negra didn't feel like a compliment. I felt pretty lost. So I turned to YouTube to find a community of other naturals. And there was Andre's system being referenced all over the place.
在古巴，我从被称为“Mulata”（混血女孩）变成了“Negra”（黑人女孩）。也就是说，你现在看起来像个黑人了。但不知何故，“Negra”听起来并不像是一种赞美。我感到非常迷茫。所以我转向YouTube寻找其他天然发质人群的社区。到处都能看到对安德烈系统的引用。
What is your caretide? That has to be the most frequently asked question. Forcière is a beautiful creation. You film me and it's most beautiful when you take care of her. The front portion of my hair is 3C. Andres Chart has gone way beyond his own line of hair care products.
你的发质类型是什么？这一定是问得最多的问题。4C发质是一种美丽的创造。你拍摄我，当你照顾好它时，它是最美的。我前额的头发是3C型。安德烈的图表已经远远超出了他自己的护发产品系列。
It's become the go-to way for many of us to understand and talk about the texture of our hair. But not everyone thinks Andre's categories are a good thing. In fact, I'm not sure they're a good thing. But his chart has definitely got me thinking about the complicated relationship African Americans have with our hair. It's a complicated relationship that goes way back. that goes way back. Thick kinky hair was considered a sign of health and wealth in parts of Africa. But in America, skin tone and hair texture was used to divide enslaved African people. Light skin and straighter hair could mean more privileges, like working in the house and not in the field. This idea of good hair and bad hair all developed during
它已成为我们许多人理解和谈论头发纹理的首选方式。但并不是每个人都认为安德烈的分类是件好事。事实上，我不确定它们是否是件好事。但他的图表确实让我开始思考非裔美国人与头发之间复杂的关系。这是一种由来已久的复杂关系。浓密紧致的头发在非洲部分地区曾被视为健康和财富的象征。但在美国，肤色和发质被用来划分被奴役的非洲人。浅肤色和较直的头发可能意味着更多的特权，比如在室内工作而不是在田间劳作。这种“好头发”和“坏头发”的观念都是在……
slavery. This idea that the straighter your hair was or the closer it was to white textured hair, the better it was. Ayanna Bird is the co-author of Hair Story, untangling the roots of black hair in America. And she says the common belief back then was, If you had straighter hair you probably had more white blood than someone who didn't have straighter hair. After slavery ended, these racist beauty standards hung on. In the early 1900s, some people tried
奴隶制时期形成的。这种观念认为，你的头发越直，或者越接近白人的发质，就越好。阿雅娜·伯德是《发之史：理清美国黑人头发的根源》一书的合著者。她说，当时普遍的看法是：如果你的头发较直，你可能比头发不直的人拥有更多的白人血统。奴隶制结束后，这些种族主义的审美标准依然存在。在20世纪初，有些人尝试……
to straighten their hair by putting oil on it and then wrapping it with heated flannel. Mothers were even wrapping their children's hair, often causing burns and a lot of hair damage. There were even black churches and certain cities that would hang a comb on the front door, and if you couldn't comb your hair with that, then you couldn't worship at that church.
通过涂油然后用加热的法兰绒包裹来拉直头发。母亲们甚至给孩子包裹头发，这经常导致烧伤和严重的头发损伤。甚至有些城市的黑人教堂会在前门挂一把梳子，如果你不能用那把梳子梳通头发，你就不能在那座教堂礼拜。
In the 1920s, hot combs were used to straighten hair, and then came a hairstyle known as the conk. You can see it on famous jazz musicians, like Cab Callaway and Duke Ellington. The conk was the name of the style, but it was also the name of the relaxer itself, which was made with a harsh chemical called sodium hydroxide or lye. And it essentially just kind of ate away at your hair and at your scalp and caused a lot of serious burns and they were not safe.
在20世纪20年代，热梳被用来拉直头发，随后出现了一种被称为“Conk”的发型。你可以在卡布·卡洛威和艾灵顿公爵等著名的爵士音乐家身上看到它。“Conk”是这种发型的名称，但它也是直发剂本身的名称，这种直发剂是用一种叫做氢氧化钠或碱液的强化学物质制成的。它基本上会腐蚀你的头发和头皮，造成许多严重的烧伤，而且非常不安全。
Some people made their own conks, sometimes with two white potatoes, an egg, and red devil brand lie, a combo that left many scalps bleeding. The conky eventually went out of style, but relaxers made with sodium hydroxide continued on and became more and more popular. The wash and set and under the dryer with a magazine became a very common image in Black Salons. But then, in the 1960s, something different started rising. We have come to register to vote and you must realize that this is a national issue, it's not a Selma issue, it's not an Alabama issue, this is a national issue. The Civil Rights Movement brought on the beginning of a new shift that was all about embracing
有些人自制“Conk”，有时用两个白土豆、一个鸡蛋和红魔牌碱液，这种组合让许多人的头皮流血。Conk最终过时了，但用氢氧化钠制成的直发剂却延续下来，并变得越来越流行。在黑人沙龙里，洗头、定型和坐在烘干机下看杂志成了非常普遍的景象。但到了20世纪60年代，一些不同的东西开始兴起。“我们来这里是为了登记投票，你们必须意识到这是一个全国性的问题，这不是塞尔玛的问题，不是阿拉巴马州的问题，这是一个全国性的问题。”民权运动带来了新的转变，核心是拥抱……
blackness, and this meant embracing your natural hair. My mom, aunties, they all did the big chop, cutting out the relaxers and wearing their afros loud and proud. This brother here, myself, all of us, were born with our hair like this, and we just wear like this. This is an interview from 1968 with former Black Panther, Kathleen Cleaver. For so many, many years, we were told that only white people were beautiful.
黑人身份，这意味着拥抱你的天然头发。我的妈妈、阿姨们，她们都进行了“大修剪”，剪掉直发剂，自豪地留着爆炸头。“这个兄弟，我自己，我们所有人，生来头发就是这样，我们就这样留着。”这是一段1968年对前黑豹党成员凯瑟琳·克利弗的采访。“多年来，我们被告知只有白人才是美丽的。”
Only straight hair, light eyes, light skin, was beautiful, and so black women would try everything they could straight in their hair, lighten their skin to look as much like white women. This is changed because black people are aware and white people are aware of the truth because white people now want natural pig. They want pigs like this. Is it beautiful? Alright. Isn't it beautiful? All right.
“只有直发、浅色眼睛、浅色皮肤才是美丽的，所以黑人女性会尝试一切可能的方法来拉直头发、美白皮肤，以尽可能看起来像白人女性。这种情况已经改变了，因为黑人和白人都意识到了真相，因为白人现在也想要天然的爆炸头。他们想要这样的爆炸头。它美吗？好吧。它不美吗？好吧。”
Yeah. Yeah. That is beautiful. Natural hair and afros were everywhere. From the fluffy frows of the Jackson Five to white celebrities like Barbara Streisand, copying the fro. It was the first time that the relaxer industry, the chemical relaxer industry was really
“是的。是的。那很美。”天然头发和爆炸头随处可见。从杰克逊五人组蓬松的爆炸头，到芭芭拉·史翠珊等模仿爆炸头的白人名流。这是化学直发剂行业第一次……
taking a hit financially, and not as many people were chemically straightening their hair. Instead of straighteners, for the first time, people were seeing products that were meant to complement their natural hair, like afro-shine, which gave the afro a bit more shine and made it glisten like a halo in the sunlight. Afro-shine, afro-shine. Fine hair, pure products of versatile. Afro-shine made for all the ways we style. Even as afros continue to be an important style, in the 1980s, a new chemical hairdo was on the rise. Just let it shine through. The Jerry Crowe created a bigger, looser curl pattern.
在经济上受到打击，不再有那么多人使用化学直发剂。人们第一次看到旨在衬托天然头发的产品，而不是直发剂，比如“Afro-shine”，它让爆炸头更有光泽，在阳光下像光环一样闪耀。“Afro-shine，Afro-shine。细软发质，多功能纯净产品。Afro-shine，为我们的各种造型而生。”即使爆炸头继续作为一种重要的发型，在20世纪80年代，一种新的化学发型正在兴起。“让它闪耀吧。”杰里卷（Jheri Curl）创造了一种更大、更松散的卷发纹理。
It was a turn away from the political statement of the Afro. The Jerry Crowe was all about fun. So the ads really shifted away from having anything to do with black culture and community building and black identity and more to just neon colors and partying and all of the advertising for Jerry Curls more about this like embracing this fun, easy to go style. Although nothing about the Jerry curl was easy. Jerry curls were the most product, heavy hairstyle that I think any people have ever known.
这是对爆炸头政治宣言的一种背离。杰里卷完全是为了好玩。所以广告完全脱离了黑人文化、社区建设和黑人身份，更多地转向霓虹色和派对，所有杰里卷的广告都更强调这种有趣、易于打理的风格。尽管杰里卷一点也不容易打理。我认为杰里卷是任何人都知道的最需要护理产品的发型。
Black people, white people, doesn't matter. Like to have a Jerry curl, you had to have all of that activator and ain't so much stuff. And you had to use it every single day. The Jerry curl was a very moist dry style. The activator that you had to put it every single day. The Jerry Crowe was a very... moist-dry style. The activator that you had to put in your hair every day was drippy and greasy,
黑人、白人，都没关系。想要留杰里卷，你必须使用所有的激活剂和各种东西。而且你必须每天都使用它。杰里卷是一种非常湿润的干发型。你每天必须涂抹的激活剂……杰里卷是一种非常……湿润的干发型。你每天必须涂抹在头发上的激活剂又粘又油腻，
and your pillow would be stained with it. Wearing a shower cap in public was quite normal. I know all of this, because when I was a kid, I had one. I had one. I had one. I had one. I had one. I had one. I had one. I had one. I had one. I had one. When the Jerry Crowe faded out, regular old relaxers were still in option. And I went back to a relaxer too.
你的枕头会被它弄脏。在公共场合戴浴帽是很正常的。我知道这一切，因为我小时候留过。我留过。我留过。我留过。我留过。我留过。我留过。我留过。我留过。我留过。当杰里卷过时后，普通的旧式直发剂仍然是一个选择。我也回到了直发剂。
Then in 2009, comedian Chris Rock produced a documentary called Good Hair. After his daughter asked him, Daddy, how come I don't have good hair? In the documentary, he refers to chemical relaxers as creamy crack because they're applied in a white paste. And even though they're toxic, some people can't seem to quit them. In one scene, he shows just how harsh the chemicals found in many relaxers can be. He meets up with this chemist who demonstrates how sodium hydroxide can eat through just about anything. Sodium hydroxide will burn through your skin.
然后在2009年，喜剧演员克里斯·洛克制作了一部名为《好头发》的纪录片。在他女儿问他：“爸爸，为什么我没有好头发？”之后。在纪录片中，他将化学直发剂称为“奶油快克”（creamy crack），因为它们是以白色膏状形式涂抹的。尽管它们有毒，但有些人似乎无法戒掉。在一个场景中，他展示了许多直发剂中的化学物质有多么严酷。他见了一位化学家，演示了氢氧化钠如何能腐蚀几乎任何东西。氢氧化钠会烧穿你的皮肤。
The chicken is your skin. Okay. So it'll go from my brown skin down to the white meat. Right. Wow. Now you realize this goes in people's heads, right? Sodium hydroxide? Yeah, people, black people, black women, some men, you know, Morse Day, Prince,
“鸡肉就是你的皮肤。好的。所以它会从我的棕色皮肤一直腐蚀到白色的肉。对。哇。现在你意识到这涂在人们的头上，对吧？氢氧化钠？是的，人们，黑人，黑人女性，一些男性，你知道，莫斯·戴，王子，”
put sodium hydroxide in their hair to straighten it out. Why would they do that? To look white. Okay, I'll put that in. I'm gonna try to keep it. You see how, is some hair come in tighter than this? This is like a maybe like a three, four. Feel it.
把氢氧化钠涂在头发上以拉直它。他们为什么要那样做？为了看起来像白人。好的，我把它放进去。我要试着保持它。你看，有些头发比这更紧密吗？这大概是3或4型。摸摸看。
Do you mind if she touch your hair? That's Annetta Dinglesmith. And I'm with her and her salon in Boston, which amazingly is called Girlfriend Hooked Me Up Salon. Everybody was saying Girlfriend, you hooked me up. So that's how I came up with the name. up salon. Smith tells me that even though the Chris Rock movie brought up some deep rooted stuff that we need to talk about, it also did actually affect her business.
你介意她摸你的头发吗？那是安内塔·丁格尔史密斯。我和她在波士顿的沙龙里，沙龙的名字叫“Girlfriend Hooked Me Up Salon”，这名字太棒了。每个人都说：“闺蜜，你帮我搞定了。”所以我就是这样想出这个名字的。史密斯告诉我，尽管克里斯·洛克的电影提出了我们需要讨论的一些根深蒂固的问题，但它确实影响了她的生意。
People used to come in every six to eight weeks to get relaxers. Some women would spend well over a thousand dollars a year on regular treatments and salons. Smith thinks the Chris Rock movie had an effect on all that. For a minute I was mad at her because you know why? Because it was affecting my money. Everybody started going natural. You know what I mean? So that did took an impact on me with me having chemical clients.
人们过去每六到八周就会来做一次直发。有些女性每年在沙龙的常规护理上花费超过一千美元。史密斯认为克里斯·洛克的电影对这一切产生了影响。“有一阵子我生她的气，你知道为什么吗？因为它影响了我的收入。每个人都开始回归天然发质。你明白我的意思吗？所以这对我那些做化学护理的客户产生了影响。”
Because not everybody wanted to put their hair out. They don't want that creamy crack. Today, Black consumer spending on relaxers is down 30% since 2011. And this brings us back to Andre Walker's hair chart. All of these newly natural people are getting on YouTube for advice and discovering the chart. Unbeknownst to me, I was on the internet one day and I was in a reading some bloggers and they were referring to the Andre Walker hair typing system.
因为不是每个人都想把头发拉直。他们不想要那种“奶油快克”。今天，黑人消费者在直发剂上的支出自2011年以来下降了30%。这就让我们回到了安德烈·沃克的发质图表。所有这些新回归天然发质的人都在YouTube上寻求建议，并发现了这张图表。我当时并不知道，有一天我在网上读一些博主的文章，他们提到了安德烈·沃克的发质分类系统。
I'm like, did I do that? Is that the one I wrote about in my book? These days, all over YouTube, there are people referencing Andre's chart, which remember categorizes hair from one to four. One A being looser curls and four C being the tightest curls. So I'm just going to be braiding my hair so I can get my afro to be like rounded into the front. So there are videos on the best creams for a 4B twist out, or how many times a week you should wash your 3B hair, or lists of protective styles for your 4C hair, and at first I found this all really helpful and positive. I mean, it's great that more people are going natural,
我心想，是我做的吗？那是我在书里写的那个吗？这些天，YouTube上到处都有人引用安德烈的图表，记住，它将头发分为1到4类。1A是较松的卷发，4C是最紧的卷发。“所以我只是要把头发编起来，这样我的爆炸头就能在前面变圆。”所以有关于4B扭转造型的最佳乳霜的视频，或者你应该每周洗几次3B头发的视频，或者4C头发的保护性发型列表，起初我发现这一切非常有帮助且积极。我的意思是，更多人回归天然发质是件好事，
and it's great that there's a system to help them to do it. But then a few people started noticing that even in this new online community of naturals, a lot of the videos were just reinforcing old bias about straighter hair being better. The videos often instruct women about how to go from very kinky hair to less kinky, straighter hair. So like from a 4C to a 3B without using chemicals. But still implying that straighter is better. You rarely see hair like this dominating hair campaigns, but you do see fluffy bouncy curly hair in all the hair campaigns.
有一个系统来帮助他们这样做也是件好事。但后来一些人开始注意到，即使在这个新的天然发质在线社区中，许多视频也只是在强化关于“直发更好”的旧偏见。视频经常指导女性如何从非常紧密的卷发变成不那么紧密、更直的头发。比如从4C变成3B，而不使用化学物质。但仍然暗示“直发更好”。你很少看到这样的头发主导头发广告，但你确实在所有头发广告中看到蓬松、有弹性的卷发。
There are people like myself who forcey hair that I literally cannot get my hand through it, so our problems are not the same. We should be given room to speak. There are people like myself who force you hair that I literally cannot get my hand through it. So our problems are not the same. We should be given room to speak. That's a post from Slumflower, a popular blogger, who makes a lot of straight talk self-care types of videos. People like ourselves do not have hair that grows downwards, our hair grows upwards. Even if my hair is a bit rough. hair grows upwards. It feels to slum flower and others, like online natural hair talk, is mostly about how to transform what we have into something else, something a little looser, that's not what our hair naturally does.
“有像我这样4C发质的人，我的手简直伸不进去，所以我们的问题是不一样的。我们应该有发言权。有像我这样4C发质的人，我的手简直伸不进去。所以我们的问题是不一样的。我们应该有发言权。”这是Slumflower的一篇帖子，她是一位受欢迎的博主，制作了很多关于自我护理的直言不讳的视频。“像我们这样的人，头发不是向下生长的，我们的头发是向上生长的。即使我的头发有点粗糙。”对于Slumflower和其他人来说，网上的天然发质讨论大多是关于如何将我们拥有的东西变成别的东西，一些更松散的东西，那不是我们头发自然的样子。
And they're using Andre's chart to do it. There's been a lot of criticism against a lot of natural hair websites that they focus too much on quote unquote 3B hair as opposed to 4C hair and that the tighter your curl pattern is and the kinkier your hair is the less represented you are on these sites. One woman I talked to said the chart feels to her like a modern day pencil test which was a test used in apartheid South Africa to figure out if someone was white or black. If you put a pencil in someone's hair and the pencil fell out, the person passed and was considered white. But Andre Walker says he just wanted to make a variety of products for different kinds
而且他们正在使用安德烈的图表来做到这一点。有很多针对天然发质网站的批评，认为它们过于关注所谓的3B发质，而不是4C发质，而且你的卷发纹理越紧、头发越紧密，你在这些网站上的代表性就越低。我采访的一位女性说，这张图表对她来说就像现代版的“铅笔测试”，这是南非种族隔离时期用来判断一个人是白人还是黑人的测试。如果你把铅笔插进某人的头发里，铅笔掉下来，那个人就通过了，被认为是白人。但安德烈·沃克说，他只是想为不同种类的……
of hair. It wasn't at all his intention to create a hierarchy. People have asked me why did I label straight hair as number one in Kinky Hair as number four? I also asked him. But my answer to that is it's going from zero texture to highly textured. So going from one being straight to four being the kinky-yes. And I've had people that have been very sensitive about that because they thought that I was giving kinky hair less importance by putting it in number four and giving straight hair more importance by being number one.
头发制作各种产品。他根本无意制造等级制度。“人们问我为什么把直发标为1号，把紧密卷发标为4号？我也问过他。但我的回答是，这是从零纹理到高度纹理的过渡。所以从1号的直发到4号的最紧密卷发。有些人对此非常敏感，因为他们认为我把紧密卷发排在4号是降低了它的重要性，而把直发排在1号是提高了它的重要性。”
But that just goes to show you how sensitive hair is, hair and texture is for a lot of people. It's true. It's so, so sensitive. And even though a lot more women are going natural, there are still so many who just don't want to. Maybe they like the way their hair looks straightened or find it easier to manage, or just don't want to deal with other people's reactions to their natural hair. Back at Girlfriend hooked me up here salon, the vet Moisa Sungga says she isn't the least bit concerned with Andre's hair chart because she doesn't want to go natural. I don't know that look I feel is not for me.
但这恰恰说明了头发和纹理对许多人来说是多么敏感。确实如此。它太敏感了。尽管越来越多的女性回归天然发质，但仍有许多人不想这样做。也许她们喜欢头发拉直后的样子，或者觉得更容易打理，或者只是不想应对别人对她们天然头发的反应。回到“Girlfriend Hooked Me Up”沙龙，维特·莫伊萨·松加说她一点也不关心安德烈的发质图表，因为她不想回归天然发质。“我不知道，我觉得那种造型不适合我。”
I don't know, there's just this, should I say fear? Or does comfort, you know, I'm not going, should I say fear? Or discomfort? You know, I'm not going to show up to an interview with Braids on, or a fro, or anything like that. It's, my hair is going to be as straight as it possibly can be, because as much as I like it or don't like it, we still live in a society where our hair is not accepted for what it is, And you have to play the game to win it. There is so much racism and colorism and years of painful history tangled up in all of this. It's deeply personal.
“我不知道，这只是一种，我该说是恐惧吗？还是不适？你知道，我不会留着编发、爆炸头或类似的东西去参加面试。我的头发会尽可能地直，因为无论我喜不喜欢，我们仍然生活在一个头发不被接受其本来面目的社会里，你必须玩这个游戏才能赢。这一切中纠缠着太多的种族主义、肤色歧视和多年的痛苦历史。这是非常私人的。”
And for those of us who have decided to go natural, it would be nice to see the hair conversation shift away from how to change our hair, and more towards how to manage the natural texture we were born with. Because my hair is still a crown, no Lila Day decodes the proud lady symbol for us, right after this. So one of the things we love to do on our show is decode little symbols that you see out in the design world. And you're here to tell us about the proud lady symbol. What is the proud lady symbol?
对于我们这些决定回归天然发质的人来说，如果能看到关于头发的讨论从“如何改变我们的头发”转向“如何打理我们与生俱来的天然纹理”，那将是一件好事。因为我的头发依然是我的皇冠。莱拉·戴将在稍后为我们解读“骄傲女士”标志。所以，我们在节目中喜欢做的一件事就是解读你在设计世界中看到的各种小符号。你在这里是为了告诉我们关于“骄傲女士”标志的事。什么是“骄傲女士”标志？
So the proud lady symbol is the symbol of this black woman with these long locks behind her and her head is held proud. And you can see the symbol on the back of some hair care products. Oh cool. And I actually grew up seeing the symbol everywhere. I just thought it was part of all the brands. But it's actually not, it has a very specific point. Okay, what's the point?
“骄傲女士”标志是一个黑人女性的符号，她身后有长长的发辫，头高高地昂着。你可以在一些护发产品的背面看到这个标志。哦，太酷了。我从小到大到处都能看到这个标志。我一直以为它是所有品牌的一部分。但实际上并非如此，它有一个非常具体的意义。好的，意义是什么？
There was an organization called the American Health and Beauty AIDS Institute. And they were founded in the 80s after a lot of black haircare products were kind of getting lost in the consumer market. There were big corporations like Revlon and Johnson and Johnson and they were sort of taking over the black hair care business.
有一个组织叫“美国健康与美容艾滋病协会”（American Health and Beauty Aids Institute）。他们成立于80年代，当时许多黑人护发产品在消费市场上逐渐迷失。像露华浓和强生这样的大公司正在接管黑人护发业务。
So they created the proud lady symbol to let people know that it's a black owned business. Oh, okay, so what do you have in your hand there? So I'm holding some Lester's pink therapeutic conditioning hairdress. I haven't used it yet. I used to use Lester's when I was a kid. But there's the proud lady symbol right on the back
所以他们创建了“骄傲女士”标志，让人们知道这是黑人拥有的企业。哦，好的，那你手里拿的是什么？我拿着一些“Lester's Pink”治疗性护发素。我还没用过。我小时候用过Lester's。但背面就有“骄傲女士”标志……
near the barcode. And yeah, it says in really tiny little writing, let me see if I can see. It says the proud lady, 100% black owned. Wow, that's great. Yeah. So to this day, do you look for that and make your choices based on that?
在条形码附近。是的，上面用非常小的字写着，让我看看能不能看清。上面写着“骄傲女士，100%黑人拥有”。哇，那太棒了。是的。所以直到今天，你还会寻找它并以此作为选择的依据吗？
I never have, you know, and it was just doing this piece that I was like, oh, that symbol, I grew up seeing that symbol. So I went to the hair care store and I looked for it over and over and over and over again. And I only saw it on a couple of products, you know. So I don't know if it's obviously not used as much as it used to be, but I kind of missing that symbol. So if you want to make informed choices,
我从来没有过，你知道，只是在做这个专题时，我才想：“哦，那个标志，我从小就看到那个标志。”所以我去了护发品店，一遍又一遍地寻找它。我只在少数几个产品上看到了它。所以我不知道它是否像过去那样被广泛使用，但我有点怀念那个标志。所以如果你想做出明智的选择，
look for the proud ladies. Yeah, look for her. She looks proud. She does. Thanks so much. Sure. [♪ music playing in background, music playing in background, 99% of visible was produced this week by Lealid Day
寻找“骄傲女士”。是的，寻找她。她看起来很骄傲。她确实很骄傲。非常感谢。不客气。[背景音乐播放，本周的《99% Invisible》由来自《The Stoop》的莱拉·戴制作。
from the stoop. Mix and tech production by Sharif Yusuf with help from senior editor Delaney Hall. Music by Sean Rial. Our senior producer is Katie Mingle, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Avery Troubleman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Masa, and me, Roman Mars. The stoop podcast is stories from across the Black diaspora hosted by Lila Day and Hanat Baba. It's conversations about
混音和技术制作由谢里夫·优素福完成，高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔提供协助。音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。我们的高级制作人是凯蒂·明格尔，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队其他成员包括艾弗里·特鲁布尔曼、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、塔伦·马萨和我，罗曼·马尔斯。《The Stoop》播客讲述的是来自黑人散居群体的故事，由莱拉·戴和哈纳特·巴巴主持。这是关于……
blackness that aren't talked about enough, like is it appropriation when African Americans wear African clothing? Or what it means when people say, you sound white. You can subscribe to this stoop wherever you get your podcasts. 99% of visible is a project of KALW in San Francisco in produced, un-radio row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a part of radio-topia from PRX, a collective of the best, most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by our listeners, just like you.
黑人身份的对话，这些话题讨论得还不够多，比如非裔美国人穿非洲服装是挪用吗？或者当人们说“你听起来像个白人”时意味着什么。你可以在任何获取播客的地方订阅《The Stoop》。《99% Invisible》是旧金山KALW的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心制作。我们是PRX旗下Radio-topia的一部分，这是一个汇集了播客界最优秀、最具创新性节目的集体。我们由像你一样的听众支持。
You can find 99% of visible and enjoyable discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me, at RomanMars in the show at 99BIOrk, or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But our true home on the internet is 99BI.org. Radio Topeo from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到《99% Invisible》以及关于节目的有趣讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99BIOrk，或者在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上关注我们。但我们在互联网上真正的家是99BI.org。Radio-topia from PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。